allez on va voir les cuisines n'hésitez
pas à mettre votre lampe torche là on
passe dans la partie qui est dans le
noir un bâtiment industriel à l'abandon
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
Paris Saclay a lancé un appel à projet
pour occuper la piano Guyancourt
association entrepreneurs ou collectifs
de nombreux profils sont envisagés pour
développer ici leur activité ce vendredi
7 juillet ils étaient une vingtaine à
avoir répondu présent une première
découverte de cette construction
singulière
occupée par la société Thalès dans les
années 90 elle accueillait d'une part le
restaurant d'entreprise pour tous les
salariés du site elle accueillait aussi
tous les espaces de réception où on
recevait les délégations pour signer des
contrats voilà concrètement et puis la
partie la partie est de la halle avait
une vocation un peu plus industrielle
c'est enthousiasmant c'est magnifique
le architecte a fait sans le Georges
Pompidou on le voit d'ailleurs ça
ressemble et c'est immense il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup de potentiel
8800 mètres carrés de surface à
exploiter cette visite de mieux prendre
conscience des espaces et de leur état
général mise hors d'eau et raccordement
au réseau c'était édifice inoccupé
depuis 15 ans bénéficiera de travaux
sommaires début 2024 avant l'arrivée de
ses futurs locataires l'objectif c'est
quand même de d'arriver à organiser un
Tetris d'organiser la l'implantation des
différentes activités dans la halle en
fonction des profils de chaque de chaque
bâtiment mais aussi des synergies qui
peut y avoir entre différents preneurs
de manière à les regrouper ensemble si
on il y a des mutualisations possibles
ce responsable administratif d'une
association est à la recherche de locaux
plus spacieux l'opportunité d'intégrer
un nouveau lieu de vie dans le futur
quartier des savoirs où s'arrêtera la
ligne 18 du Grand Paris Express
j'attendais aussi d'éventuellement de
projeter voir si ça peut coller avec le
projet qu'on met en place c'est
intéressant c'est que le bâtiment dans
lequel on est de la prévention c'est là
où je me suis dit en arrivant à c'est
l'endroit qui est le plus à mon activité
enfin l'activité de ressources cette
première phase du candidature se
déroulera jusqu'au 22 septembre prochain
à l'automne 2023 l'établissement public
d'aménagement de Paris Saclay décidera
des structures pertinentes pour occuper
cet alpiano nouvelle version ouverture
prévue fin 2024